>>> HERE'S A STAT THAT STANDS
OUT.
THE NONPARTISAN GROUP STATES
UNITED ACTION SAYS 9 IN 10
ELECTION DENIERS RUNNING FOR
STATEWIDE OFFICE LOST.
MOST OF THEM DID THE NORMAL
THING MEANING THEY CONCEDED AND
BOWED OUT.
ARIZONA REPUBLICAN KARI LAKE,
HOWEVER, NOT AMONG THEM.
>> IT WAS RUN LIKE A RUN
ELECTIONS IN A BANANA REPUBLIC.
AND PEOPLE RUNNING IT WERE THE
NUMBER ONE POLITICAL GOAL WAS TO
MAKE SURE I DIDN'T GET ELECTED.
>> LAKE, THE FORMER LOCAL NEWS
ANCHOR, SHE LOST THE RACE FOR
ARIZONA GOVERNOR.
SHE'S NOW SUING HER 70-PAGE
LAWSUIT RECYCLES SOME 2020 MYTHS
AND ALLEGES WITHOUT ANY EVIDENCE
THAT THIS YEAR, THOUSANDS OF
VOTES WERE CAST ILLEGALLY AND
THAT REPUBLICANS WERE UNIQUELY
DISENFRANCHISED BY LONG LINES.
OUR GREATER REPORT GREAT REPORT
WITH US.
SHE'S BEEN CONSISTENT ABOUT
THIS, SHE'S AN ACOLYTE OF DONALD
TRUMP.
SHE SAID IT WAS STOLEN IN 2020.
IF YOU READ THE LAWSUIT, SHE HAS
EVERY RIGHT TO FILE IT.
BUT A LOT OF IT IS RECYCLING
2020 STUFF.
THERE'S NO EVIDENCE TO BACK UP
FOR THIS YEAR'S STUFF.
>> IT'S A DIFFERENT CONTEXT THAN
TRUMP AND 2020 AND 2019, WHILE
THERE IS STILL A WELL-TRODDEN
KIND OF MEDIA CIRCUIT TO RUN,
USING THESE KINDS OF CLAIMS NO
MATTER HOW MANY TIMES THEY WERE
REJECTED BY A COURT I THINK ALL
OF US ARE DIFFERENT.
THE MEDIA ENVIRONMENT IS
DIFFERENT.
AS YOU CAN SEE FROM THE DOMINION
VOTING MACHINES LAWSUIT, THE
SORT OF PATIENCE THAT SOME
PEOPLE HAVE FOR THIS KIND OF
BEHAVIOR HAS WORN REALLY THIN.
>> AND, LOOK, THERE'S SOME
PATIENCE THAT'S BEEN LOST AMONG
REPUBLICANS, TOO, MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS, PEOPLE WHO HAVE SEEN
WHAT HAPPENED, THE ELECTION
CYCLE LAST WEEK.
THE NUMBER TWO REPUBLICAN, JOHN
THUNE TOLD ME THAT INDEPENDENT
VOTERS WERE JUST NOT HAVING ALL
OF THE ELECTION DENIALISM
HAPPENING IN THE GOP RANKS.
THEY REJECTED THOSE WHO EMBRACED
THAT THEORY.
LEADERSHIP TYPES, THEY THOUGHT
THIS WAS THE WRONG WAY TO GO,
HOW DO GOP VOTERS AND HOW DO
SOME CANDIDATES IN THE STATES
FEEL.
>> IN SOME WAY IS THIS A
REFRESHING MAP.
AFTER 2020, WE HAD LAWSUITS AND
RECOUNT DEMANDS AND PROTESTS IN
BATTLEGROUND STATE AFTER
BATTLEGROUND STATE.
THIS YEAR, THERE'S A RECOUNT
GOING ON, VOTING RIGHTS PASSED
IN MICHIGAN.
ELECTION DENIERS ARE PAYING FOR
THE RECOUNTS FOR THE BALLOTS.
THAT'S THEIR RIGHT.
IN COLORADO, THIS IS A RECOUNT
IN A CONGRESSIONAL RACE THAT WAS
VERY CLOSE EVEN THOUGH THE DEM
HAS CONCEDED.
IT'S PRETTY ROUTINE.
HERE YOU HAVE NOW, KARI LAKE
SUING THE CONTESTED IN ARIZONA.
>> THE THING ABOUT EVEN THOUGH
THERE ARE SOME REPUBLICANS IN
LEADERSHIP WHO ARE SAYING THIS
IS CLEARLY NOT A WINNING
STRATEGY, NONE OF THEM ARE
SAYING THEY WON'T SUPPORT TRUMP
IF HE'S THE NOMINEE UNTIL 2024.
AND THE POLL TODAY, OUT FROM CNN
SHOWS THAT THE REPUBLICAN BASE
STILL VERY MUCH BELIEVES WHAT
KARI LAKE IS PEDDLING WHICH IS
SOME 65% OF REPUBLICANS SAY THAT
THEY THINK IT'S OKAY TO ACCEPT
AN ELECTION DENIER.
>> LET'S SHOW THE NUMBERS
BECAUSE IT IS STRIKING.
YOU COULD ARGUE IT'S DOWN SOME,
BUT ALSO A HORRIFIC NUMBER.
IT WAS 72%, NOW, IT'S 65%.
SO, THAT'S HEADING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION IN THE SENSE THERE'S
ZERO EVIDENCE BUT STILL
TWO-THIRDS.
>> BUT WE'RE ALL USING THE TERM
KIND OF ELECTION DENIERS VERY
BROADLY.
REMEMBER, IT WASN'T JUST A
REJECTION OF THESE PEOPLE AND
THEIR PERSONALITIES.
IT WAS ALSO SOME POLICY
SUGGESTIONS THAT CAME ALONG WITH
THIS IDEOLOGY, RIGHT?
YOU'D HEAR CANDIDATES SAYING
WE'RE GOING TO DEREGISTER EVERY
VOTER AND EVERYONE HAS TO
REREGISTER.
NO ONE WANTS THAT.
YOU'RE HEARING PEOPLE SAY NO
MORE EARLY VOTING THIS AND THAT.
TONS OF CONVENIENCES THAT THE
VOTERS HAVE COME TO EMBRACE IN
BIG NUMBERS.
SO THEY'RE ASKING FOR A ROLLING
BACK OF THINGS THAT THE VOTERS
THEMSELVES ARE STARTING TO
APPROVE OF AND ENJOY.
AND I THINK THAT'S WHERE IT GETS
A LITTLE WOBBLY IN TERMS OF
BACKING THE STYLE OF CANDIDATE
GOING FORWARD.
>> BUT, AS YOU SAY, GETTING A
LITTLE WOBBLY, AND YET, YET, IN
THE NEW HOUSE REPUBLICAN
MAJORITY, THERE ARE STILL A
NUMBER OF ELECTION DENIERS AND
TRUMP ACOLYTES, AMONG THEM
MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE WHO WAS
ONCE ON THE FRINGE.
SHE IS NOW HELPING VERY MUCH
KEVIN McCARTHY WHO WANTS TO BE
SPEAKER, HELPING HIM TRY TO GET
THE VOTES.
I WANT YOU TO LISTEN TO HER OVER
THE WEEKEND.
JANUARY 6th, POLICE OFFICERS
WERE KILLED THE VICE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES LIFE WAS
THREATENED.
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE'S LIFE WAS
EVERYBODY IN THAT BUILDING WAS
THREATENED.
MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE SAYS IF
SHE AND STEVE BANNON HAD BEEN IN
CHARGE --
>> IF STEVE BANNON AND I HAD
ORGANIZED THAT, WE WOULD HAVE
WON.
NOT TO MENTION --
>> WHEW, WHEW.
>> YEAH.
THEY SAY THAT WHOLE THING WAS
PLANNED, I'M LIKE, ARE YOU
KIDDING ME, WITH CONSERVATIVE
SECOND AMENDMENT REPORTERS WERE
IN CAPITOL WITHOUT GUNS, THEY
THINK WE ORGANIZED THAT?
I DON'T THINK SO.
>> WE WOULD HAVE WON.
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN ARMED.
MY WORDS, NOT HERS.
MORE PEOPLE LIKELY WOULD HAVE
BEEN HURT OR KILLED.
THE ELECTION, THE PROCEEDINGS
WOULD HAVE BEEN STOPPED.
WINNING, THEY WOULD HAVE STOPPED
THE CERTIFICATION OF THE
ELECTION.
MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE THINKS
THAT'S A GOOD THING.
WE HAVE HEARD FROM LEADERS WHAT?
>> YEAH, NOTHING.
BECAUSE OF THE CLOUT SHE NOW HAS
WITHIN THE HOUSE REPUBLICAN
CONFERENCE.
KEVIN McCARTHY NEEDS MARJORIE
TAYLOR GREENE RIGHT NOW TO
BECOME ELECTED SPEAKER.
WHY?
BECAUSE HE HAS A PROBLEM ON THE
FAR RIGHT OF THIS CONFERENCE.
OF WHICH SHE IS A PART.
SHE IS ENDORSING HIM.
HE CAN ONLY AFFORD TO LOSE FOUR
REPUBLICAN VOTES TO BECOME
SPEAKER.
HE ALREADY HAS FOUR OR FIVE
SAYING NO.
MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE IS TRYING
GET HIM ELECTED SPEAKER.
AND PROBABLY BET SHE'S GOING TO
GET INFLUENTIAL COMMITTEE
ASSIGNMENTS AS A RESULT.
WHEN SHE SAYS OUTLANDISH
CONTROVERSIAL THINGS YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO HEAR MUCH PUSHBACK.
>> WE WOULD HAVE WON, IT WOULD
HAVE BEEN ARMED -- IS THERE ANY
JOB IN AMERICA, ANY POWER WORTH
NEEDING THAT VOTE?
>> THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION FOR
KEVIN McCARTHY.
CLEARLY HE AND MITCH McCONNELL
HAVE SAID THEY HAVEN'T DRAWN ANY
RED LINES REALLY WITH ANY OF
THESE ELECTION DENIERS.
WHAT MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE IS
SAYING RIGHT THERE, SHE WOULD
HAVE BEEN HAPPY TO CARRY OUT A
TREASONIST ATTACK ON THE
GOVERNMENT -- TR